From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good morning. I'm Emilye Crosby. It's December 10th, 2015. We're at the Library of Congress with Juadine Henderson.
And this is part of the Civil Rights History Project, co-sponsored by the Library of Congress and the Civil Rights History Project.
I'm sorry, the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
And with us is John Bishop.
Can you tell us first of all just thank you for joining us and doing your view?
Can you tell us when and where you're born and about your family?
Yes, I was born in Batesville, Mississippi, Panola County.
My parents were Lyora Morris and Hugo Henderson. We were farmers.
We had a small farm where we grew cotton, corn, okra, soybeans, so I'd be major.
And that was about it. My dad died when I was about four or five. We're not sure of all the circumstances.
So I grew up basically with my mother who was married again when I was ten. And that's when we moved to the farm.
So that's when you began farming?
Yeah. Before that did you live in town?
I lived in town but we could hire ourselves out to local farmers.
So I bought my first coat when I was five from picking cotton.
Yeah. You appreciate that coat?
Oh, yes, of course. Oh, I have to count my money every day. 25 cents now.
How did you feel about picking cotton?
It was natural, normal, it was fine. We also picked pecans.
So it was good.
When your mother remarried and you moved to the farm did you family own that land?
Yes.
Yes. It was 80 acres and one group of brothers owned one side of the road.
They have first cousins that another group of brothers owned the other side.
And it was called Section 7.
And we are everybody referred to it as 7.
You're going to 7?
At the time were you aware of the difference that made the only own land?
No.
Anything to do?
No, it did not.
Before we moved to the farm my mom worked in a restaurant in town.
It was called Brown's Cafe.
And I would go in on Saturdays to be with her.
So she allowed me to wash dishes when I went in and I had on an apron and it was all the way to the floor.
And I was curious about why we had to stay in the kitchen.
What happens outside here?
And she said, well, the next tray of glasses that you wash do not stop walking until you get out front with them.
That was my first little experience. I think I was about eight years old.
So I walked my glasses out front and looked around and went, they're just eating.
Did you think there was something really exciting?
No, I was like, oh, that's different.
Did you have any brothers and sisters?
Yes, I have two older sisters and one younger sister and a brother who is no longer here.
He died about five years ago.
What were your school's like?
Well, I started school at age three because my grandmother was the teacher.
And she was also my babysitter. So I had to go to school with her every day.
And it was a church owned. I guess it was a public school but it was run by the church somehow.
And it was one through eight grades in that one little building.
I think.
Yeah, it was just for community kids.
It was Olive Ray School next to Olive Ray Church.
And I went into any class I wanted to because when it was your time to go into for your class,
they would go to the front seat and I would join them.
And I had to do homework at night. So it was kind of fun.
I learned to read and write fairly early, like 3 or 4.
Was it hard when you were actually with your own class?
Yes, it was because I was bored.
My mother wouldn't allow me to move ahead. She wanted me with my age group.
So they were learning alphabet and I wanted to play.
So yeah, yeah, I had done that.
So that was hard. I got in trouble a lot.
I was ordered to the corner a lot. Stand in the corner, Maria.
No, this was the real public school with other people.
So when did you start going to a different public school?
Oh, and I was six.
Okay, so you went with your grandmother to her school, but you went to a different school?
A public school and I turned six, yes.
What was that school like?
Different kids from all over people to play with. It was good.
You mentioned being at the restaurant and being curious.
What are some of your memories of breaks and how you learn about it?
Well, when I started school at age six, we went to school on a farm work as truck.
A truck came by in the mornings and the man got out and put a ladder down and we climbed up.
The white kids went past us on the school bus and we yelled at each other and waved.
But also in my little neighborhood, the family across the road from us was white.
Apparently poor because they wouldn't have been there otherwise.
And we played with the kids, but one person had to look out for their father.
When we saw their father's car coming, they had to go around through the back and come go home.
And he couldn't know that they were overplaying with us.
Did you think about that at the time?
We just knew that somebody had to watch out for their father's car.
No, didn't really meet anything to me.
And then it started to meet something.
When I was working with my mother in that restaurant at age eight and seeing all the black people who came to the restaurant,
ate in the kitchen with her.
And then there were these other people and we could not see what they were doing out front and that was different.
And then of course when I was also eight, I think it was when the Emmett Till murder happened.
And my mom bought me a copy.
I think it was Look Our Life magazine.
I'm not sure.
And Jet Magazine.
And of course I knew then there was something seriously wrong out there.
I read the stories.
I cried for his parents more than him.
Thinking what would mother do if somebody did that to me.
You know?
Yeah.
So that was about eight when I really knew something was seriously wrong in the neighborhood.
When your mother gave those to you, did she talk to you about it?
No, not really.
Yeah.
No, I just read it.
Because I tried to read everything I could find.
And she gave me that.
I read it.
And was sad for his mom more than anything.
And we didn't discuss it.
And you didn't talk about it with other kids?
No.
Yeah.
There were a lot of things that we never talked about.
You know?
And that was one of them.
We never talked them.
And there was a meeting.
I think probably in double-acp meeting in our house.
We had two rooms.
It was a little storehouse.
It had been a store.
And we, the kitchen and the living room was where we slept.
You know?
And there was a meeting there.
And I was not allowed.
You know, I could stay in the back and do whatever I was doing.
And I found my mother's in double-acp card and said,
what is this?
What is in double-acp?
I didn't say in double-acp.
And she said, you must never, ever say that again.
Ever.
I was like, okay.
Whatever it is.
It must be very serious.
And we never discussed what they were talking about in the next
room.
But at church on Sundays, the minister talked about everything.
We talked about the kids in Little Rock who had just integrated the schools there.
Voter registration things that had not really started.
I think there were two people in the county, two black people registered to vote.
And we just sort of heard that on Sundays.
There was an older minister, Reverend Middleton, God-free, that's his name.
And I hated to see him coming on Sundays because it meant we had to stay at church,
another half an hour to listen to black history.
He traveled around in a little bit up Jeep and he talked history.
And you could almost work your mouth.
He said the same thing every time we knew who Crispus Attucks was.
So you were like the black history of our culture?
Yeah, but he did it every Sunday.
Oh, no, every other Sunday because we didn't have church every Sunday.
We had Sunday school and other stuff.
So what was your church?
West Camp Missionary Baptist Church.
Initially, until my mom got married.
Was it West camp missionary where you had these Sunday schools?
I mean, it talks about black history.
Yeah, and it was one of the most active churches in the county
throughout the Civil Rights Movement.
When they would talk about voting or NAACP or any decent in church,
and black history was this part of the service or before?
It was after the service.
After you finished, you can't say that.
After they were finished with the traditional service,
and the guests will stand up and introduce themselves.
And then they talked about what was going on in other southern places,
like Clarksdale, Mississippi, Arkansas.
And we didn't talk that much about what was going on in our own town.
So what's in the news?
What was going on in the NAACP mainly was involved with.
There were a couple of brothers, CJ Williams,
and his brother were active, and Mr. Robert Miles,
of course, who stayed active, and Mr. Willie Kirkendall.
It came sort of to a head because Mr. Kirkendall's daughter,
who was younger than I am, went to town and was accused of stealing.
The sheriff brought her to a dad and said, you have to beat her.
And the child said, she didn't steal, and the dad said, I'm not beating my child.
And you didn't say no to the sheriff.
And the energy and the neighborhood changed.
I don't know how to explain that other than you knew it was really serious.
And near nightfall, you saw all of the men,
or most of the men walking down the road with their guns on their shoulders
to the Kirkendall house.
They sent the women and children away,
but then they climbed into the trees and the trucks to protect the house,
the family, so to speak.
And the Kirkendall family moved away.
I never actually saw them again.
They went to Indiana, found out later.
So you knew something was seriously wrong then.
But it wasn't the nonviolent movement stuff had not happened.
Like we will protect ourselves.
What, do you remember how old you were when this happened?
I had to be eight or nine.
It seems to me everything happened when I was eight.
I don't know.
Eight or nine, because we still lived in our little two-room house in town.
And so this would have been, so probably around 55?
Oh, way after that.
Probably later 50s, maybe early 60s.
And Mr. Kirkendall was superintendent of the Sunday school,
so everybody knew him.
Did your family talk about that one?
Oh, no. It was just my mom and me.
So no, we didn't discuss it.
Did you remember what age you were,
or how you came to understand what the NAACP was,
other than this card that you can't talk about?
I think I was probably 13.
It was after we had moved to the farm.
And Frank Smith, the SNCC person, came to town in 1962.
The Thanksgiving.
He didn't come to do movement work.
Mm-hmm.
And my cousin, he met my cousin at Rust College, Holly Springs.
And I ran up to their house across the road to hear about college.
And what you do at college in.
And there was a stranger there.
So I said, hello.
And he told me about the Civil Rights Movement.
Now, we knew about the Freedom Rights
because it was in the newspaper.
We got the commercial appeal from Memphis.
And he actually knew people who were involved.
He was involved.
I found it fascinating.
And I talked, and we talked, then I told him that
the uncle to one of the men who killed him at Till lived in the neighborhood.
And got in the car with him and showed him the house.
You know?
And we came back home.
And then I was so excited.
I went home and mother said, you got into a stranger's car.
He's not a stranger.
He's his friend.
And I told her what he told me about black people voting.
And she had had the right to vote.
And that there are no black people in Batesville who voted.
And if they did, we could change the whole system.
And mother was looking at me like, yeah, right.
Okay.
Go play.
Go do something else.
So that was really the beginning.
We stayed in touch with Frank.
I told all of my friends about him.
And the movement.
I think we had a meeting at my house.
But I didn't tell my mom because she would have said no.
And then I told her, you know, I was like, what are you doing?
And I told her, you know, I was like, what are you doing?
And we had a meeting.
And we had, I was the pianist at church.
I played piano every Sunday at our new church.
That was Concord Missionary Baptist Church.
And I knew that the church wasn't locked.
So after the initial meeting at our house, we went to church and had a meeting.
We didn't ask anybody.
We just went.
Uh-huh.
We took a record player.
And Frank brought with him a copy of the Freedom in the Air.
So we got to hear what Freedom Songs sound like.
Is that freedom in the air?
It was called the Albany Movement, I think.
Uh-huh.
But Bernice Johnson Reagon was definitely a singer on there.
So we could do that now.
Um, it was wonderful.
It was like, mainly you put freedom in places where Jesus had been.
That was very good.
So we knew how to do that.
Because my girlfriends and me, we are now like 13, 14.
And we could sing Freedom Songs.
And we did.
You didn't worry about messing with the church songs?
No.
I didn't.
They did.
I didn't need that.
The elders.
What was the reason?
Well, it didn't come to a head right then.
Later when the preacher finished preaching,
and I was supposed to play Amazing Grace, I played O Freedom.
And survived.
Some people got very upset and said the child has lost her mind.
And yeah, I had.
Yeah.
So you said who you were telling us about how you played O Freedom instead of Amazing Grace?
Yes.
And then you started to say that you heard something about your mother?
Yeah.
Before that, the summer of 63, we met Frank at Thanksgiving 1962.
Okay.
And Frank, I thought as an adult, he was 19 years old, I think.
And he told us about a voter registration workshop that was going to be held in Greenwood, Mississippi.
And he wanted us to come.
Mother didn't let me have dates.
So it was like, okay, how am I going to get to this workshop?
I packed my bag and it eased it under the bed, the storage place.
Because I was going.
I was hearing words that I'd never heard before.
But that happened in Greenwood.
After my dad's death, she didn't do anything.
She didn't make decisions for me alone.
She had a brother who she consulted.
And I wanted to go to Greenwood.
So he was a dry cleaner truck driver.
He came to our house as he did on Mondays.
And she said,
Juadine wants to go with those freedom people to Greenwood.
And he said, Jimmy's going, Jimmy was my older cousin.
She was three years older.
Free, it was freedom.
Like, oh yeah, we're going.
And he said, if anything happens and you need to come home, call somebody.
We didn't have telephones.
There was one telephone in the neighborhood.
And everybody had the number.
So if something happened and your family needed to contact you, they called that number and they would let you know.
So we headed to Greenwood, Mississippi.
June, 1963.
It was my cousin, Jimmy.
My friend, Fay.
John Hardy.
And I think that was it.
Three of us.
And T, my cousin, John Morris, who was a college student.
Jimmy was also a college student.
And we went to Greenwood.
Very excited about being able to get away from home without your mother and all of that.
With these freedom people.
And we got to the Greenwood Snick Office.
And looked around and people were talking on the phone.
Very hushed and very serious.
And we sort of took it in and sat there and watched.
Then we were taken across the street to stay with a woman named Mama Hackman.
That was all we knew.
And everybody was very friendly.
They were kids our age, talking to us and pulling our legs a little bit too.
Because we were going to go to a mass meeting that evening.
And I didn't know mass, M-A-S-S, from mask.
M-A-S-K.
It was like, what are we supposed to do at this meeting?
And one of the girls said, you have to hold a hand with the person you're with and walk in.
Do we wear anything?
Nope.
You just go ahead.
And we went to the meeting and people could, we heard freedom sing songs.
How they were really supposed to sound in person.
At that meeting that night, it was very nice.
And younger people, you know, just a little bit older than we were singing and leading songs.
And it was very nice.
We went back to Mama Hackman's house.
I don't know where we ate.
And then the next morning we went in to the SNCC office.
And it was a very different energy.
People weren't as friendly as they had been the day before.
It was very strange.
It was like, what is going on?
We sat there and was quiet for a second or two.
And then a kid who called himself freedom.
I don't know what freedom's name was.
Came in and we said, what's going on freedom?
Why is everybody so sad?
And he said, Medgar Evans was killed last night in Jackson.
It was like, oh, oh.
We got to go home.
Jimmy said, you think we need to call daddy?
He said, no, we're here. We're staying.
And so we stayed and they told us they were going to canvas the neighborhood.
And we heard a canvassing.
No. Okay, what is that?
We're going to walk around from house to house, passing out leaflets, inviting people to a meeting.
A mass meeting.
Okay.
So we went with the local kids, walked around the neighborhood, passing out leaflets, saying there was a meeting at 11 o'clock at some church or the other.
We went.
There were more people at that church than I had ever seen gathered in one place in Batesville.
You know, it was amazing.
And people that we met had met the day before in the SNCC office were up leading songs and talking.
I don't remember what they said.
It was just the energy.
And my cousin and me tried to sing as loud as we could.
We wanted to.
Like, we know how to sing freedom songs now.
But it was talking about what was going on in Jackson.
I don't remember specifics, but being very energized by the whole thing.
We went back to the SNCC office and had workshops.
A workshop, put it over there, that is.
On filling out voter registration forms.
And at that gathering, I think I met John O'Neal, who was with the Free Southern Theater later.
Willie Peacock, who was major freedom fighter in Mississippi from Charleston.
James Peacock, his brother.
And they were talking about voter registration.
How to fill out the forms.
And it was necessary for black people to be able to register to vote in their neighborhoods.
And how they get to elect people to office.
That was amazing to me.
And then we were saying every day.
Did you connect voting for things in your life for your community?
No, because we, I told you there were two people as far as I knew in the county who were registered voters.
I think Robert Miles, Robert Miles, and maybe Reverend Middleton.
I'm not sure of that.
When they're telling you about it and you're thinking about it and everything.
Yeah, of course.
Because are you seeing what you have?
In that context, do you think about how it might affect the New Year world?
A little bit. Well, what they were saying.
But you started thinking about it.
You haven't paid a lot of attention to elections.
You need, we need to be a part of that.
It was something you read about in school, not something you did.
You know, not voting.
So yeah, we connected, we connected the dots a little bit.
And then interpreting a section of the Constitution.
The state constitution. Okay.
It was schoolwork.
And filling out the forms.
They were very long.
We practiced filling them out.
People how to do it.
When we went back home.
We were only in Greenwood for a week.
I think while we were gone, and I'm not sure if this.
June Johnson, who is from Greenwood, (Fannie Lou) Hamer who is from Ruleville,
Euvester Simpson, who was from Itta Bena, I think, came up missing.
And they sent Lawrence Guyot. off to look for them.
Eavesdropping, okay? We weren't a part of the major discussions with our kids, but it was all interesting information.
And we had to go home after a week. And a couple of SNCC people took us back to Batesville, and we were trying to tell them about our town and what happens there.
Batesville at the time, I think, was 54% black, no black voters. And we weren't all the 3,000 people who lived in the neighborhood didn't all live next to each other. We were scattered. We were farmers. And a few people had other kinds of jobs, but very few.
Did a lot of African Americans only land in that area? Yeah, actually, yes.
Did there wasn't nearly as much sharecropping? No, there was one plantation that I knew about in our part of the county, because there was Northern Phenola County in Southern, South Phenola County.
South Phenola County people owned their land pretty well. There was a plantation, the Macmillan plantation where sharecroppers lived.
And their little houses sat next to each other. We knew their kids, because we all went to school together. And we didn't think about them in a differently accept they lived on the plantation, on the Macmillan plantation.
It wasn't that big, you know? Now, in retrospect, it wasn't that big, it's just they didn't own their own land.
I wanted to... Is Phenola part of the Delta?
Part of it. Half of Phenola County is in the Delta, and the other half is Hill Country.
So which half is the where African Americans only land? So where is it? Split. Split.
We lived in the Delta. Yeah. Yeah.
You mentioned that while you were in Greenwood, (Fannie Lou) Hamer and doing jobs and who was a native of Greenwood, against you, that's their Simpson, and they come up and they're seen in Lawrence, he got good food.
To look for them.
How do you find out what happened to them?
Later. We didn't find out while we were there.
How did you come to find out?
Somebody told us. I don't know.
I stayed in touch with SNCC people after that one week experience, another group of kids from my town went to Greenwood to do the voter registration workshop.
And I looked at the newspaper differently, looked for stories about people I had met, you know?
We didn't find out about Miss Hamer and June Johnson. I knew June's sister Dorothy. She was, I think, my age.
We found out later, but not from the newspaper. And I don't really remember how.
Oh, I know from the group of kids who went after we did.
Okay. You came back from the group.
How did you feel when you found that out?
It didn't really do anything. It didn't register. It wasn't fear. It was, you know, I think that Larsky, we knew was beaten after that during that time.
I didn't really know Miss Hamer. I didn't know June. I had met her mother and her sister when I was in Greenwood.
You vest, I didn't know either. So these were strangers to me.
And there wasn't a real connection until later.
Until later, you know only men in the middle.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah, yeah. Of course.
What, what did you do when you got back from the workshop? Did you start doing movement work?
Trying. We would run around and, well, harass, I harassed my mother.
And my stepfather about registering to vote and how important it was that black people elected officials in our town.
And they sort of listened, but, you know, okay, mother said, I think those people hypnotized you.
Well, you and Greenwood, you didn't come back the same person that you were when you went.
Just like, no.
So it was, it was trying to show people how to fill out the forms, trying to get my mother and stepfather to register to vote at least to try.
And people had meetings in the neighborhood to talk about it, not mass meetings, but a few people got together to talk about it.
And that went on. This was 63. The very next summer was the summer of 64. The summer project of all of these people came to town.
Now, I will admit on tape that I was sort of little resentful that all of these people came out to stare at these new people.
And we've been begging you to do this for a year.
So, okay, that was that. And the whole movement in Batesville changed, I think.
You had a lot more people coming together. We got to meet kids from other parts of the county who were active.
It was on, you know.
I was in the summer project when you were working in 63 and you're trying to get people to register.
Are there any SNCC people staying in town for hours?
No, no. Frank came back some time.
Willie Blue, who was also a SNCC organizer, came to town for a while.
The Keller came to town for a while. There was no office.
They came and lived with a family someplace, you know. Mainly Robert Miles.
Yeah, but there wasn't a SNCC office until the summer of 64.
So, were they organizing you all or were you organizing yourself?
We were both. They were organizing us and talking to us and we were organizing ourselves.
You know, we live here. We know what's going on.
And that's basically what my mom said in 64. You can continue to do what you've been doing.
But don't hang out with these white children. They are going to leave and you're going to be here.
Say, how? Okay.
Did that make sense to you?
No.
Did you listen to it?
No. I got in trouble because there was an office in town. I think it was co-full office by then.
Council of Federated Organizations.
And we lived 10 miles away in the country.
And we had gone out to do whatever we were doing. And by the time we got back to the office, it was late.
And there was no ride home.
So, we had to get a ride home with a young white man from Harvard, Jeffrey "Jeff" Cowan.
And I thought, you know, mother's not going to see, she saw everything.
And Jeff dropped us off. He had a sunbeet up car. He dropped me off.
And mother had a fly swatter.
I'm 16, I think.
I'm 17, I don't know. But she hit me with the fly swatter. I told you not to ride around here with these white children.
Like, how was I supposed to get home? 10 miles away, mother.
And she let it go. She let it go.
Worry is the word.
That was mainly it. She was worried that something would happen.
You know, nothing did. Not yet.
Did you ever have any luck getting your mother and your stepfather to register?
Yes, they registered in 1964.
My stepfather had to interpret Section 30 of the Mississippi Constitution.
He memorized the thing. Well, he's filling out his voter registration form.
And he talked it all night long.
And they said, interpret Section 30 of the Mississippi Constitution. It said.
No, it's like...
Of course, he had had a little drink too. That helped.
But he said the whole section all night long.
They were very proud of themselves. They both passed.
Was it their first time out?
Yes, they did.
Did you get it?
No. If they did, they didn't tell me.
Yeah.
Tell me about some of the older people in Phenola who were involved in the movement?
That was Robert Miles. I told you he was from West Camp. Mr. C.J. Williams,
who had gone to an all black boarding school, Piney Woods,
you had gone to school there.
And his brother, Jasper, that was his name, Jasper Williams.
And there was a Robinson family. They were also West Camp people.
Pearl Robinson and her daughter Claire.
Miss Virgil Robinson, who was also from West Camp. Everybody was from West Camp.
Is that the area where people were in their own land?
People owned their own land.
Everywhere.
All over the place. Yeah.
The minister probably helped a lot.
But you had to tuck our brothers.
And the Pinolian, the local newspaper did a feature on them a couple of years ago.
Really?
Uh-huh.
And they were very active, but they had traced their ancestry back to Guinea.
He said he was from the Guinea tribe in Africa.
And I thought, that's not a tribe, but that's okay.
They were very active.
So they had a whole sense of self-worth, I think, the folks in Pinola County,
the land owners.
People tried to send it because there were no high schools for black kids
until the 50s, I think.
Because my older step-sister went to Rust College High School.
My grandmother went away to school.
My mother stayed in eighth grade for three years because she couldn't go to high school.
You know?
So she just kept going to school and going to school in eighth grade.
She...
I know people do that.
I know kidding.
Oh, I'm glad to hear that.
Yeah, because they would have them repeat seven or eight grade a couple of times
since they're in high school.
Yeah.
And also because sometimes they wouldn't get to go the whole year.
Well, we had split sessions until I graduated from high school.
So we could get out and work on the farm.
We got out to chop cotton.
And then we got out to pick cotton.
All the white kids were going to school and we were out working.
You know?
Did you think about that at the time?
No.
No, it was just normal.
It was something.
Yeah.
And we weren't our own farm, so it was different.
So did the young people in Pinola County, did you all want to get involved in direct action?
I know, in some counties, the young people got tired of all the registration.
Yeah, we did.
We got involved.
We went to them.
In 1964, I think it was, we went to the same restaurant where my mom had worked.
Mother quit her job at the restaurant saying,
if they come out, anybody put their hands on you, I'm coming out of the kitchen with a knife.
So I'm going to quit.
And she quit and got a job in the neighborhood at the local restaurant.
So blackresser.
So you didn't get ready to go.
If you didn't know what to expect, she had to listen to the radio for a while
to find out whether I was at school or in jail.
But we went to the restaurant where she had worked.
And I knew the waitress and the owners because my mom had worked there.
You know?
And we walked in, we had practice falling out into chairs and, you know, nonviolent workshops and covering ourselves.
And we were told not to talk.
Didn't mean that we couldn't talk through our teeth like this.
So we went to the restaurant in town.
I don't remember how many of us, maybe 14?
Quite a few.
Was it even boys and girls?
Mostly girls, I think they were couple of boys.
John Hardy, junior Robinson, who was the youngest, I think he was 13-14.
His mom was Mrs. Virgil Robinson.
Excuse me.
We went into the restaurant and Miss Lill, the waitress who had been there when my mother worked there, walked over by us and said,
we are not drinking any cake and eating any milk in here today.
She was nervous.
And it was like, okay.
We sat there like we were supposed to do waiting patiently.
And then we saw the sheriff come in.
So a girl, we're going to get it now.
To my girlfriend, Fay, Fay, go over.
And after the sheriff came in, some farmers came in putting on their brown cotton gloves.
Oh, oh.
Is there white farmers?
Oh, yeah.
They're walking in and they're going behind the counter.
We have the waitress normally is, and we are sitting there in our little booths thinking,
I want to know what they're going to do now.
And they came in and they started grabbing the seats we were on and slinging them across the floor and we were holding on.
Like we're not falling yet.
And then they started picking us up bodily and throwing us out into the street in front of cars or whatever.
And they took a couple of people and banged their heads together.
And they got us all out.
Nobody was arrested yet.
How did you feel when you had a new co-oper this violent?
It was a little scary because I didn't know what to expect.
You know, a little scary.
Not being super scared, but a little scared.
And so we said there's another restaurant in town in a slunch time.
Let's go down there.
And so off we went to the next restaurant.
Batesville is a tiny little town.
They aren't like big, they weren't big restaurants.
And so we went and they locked the door.
They saw us coming.
And the guys in the pool hall across the way came out with their pool cues.
They were like, oh they're going to be an astronaut.
They didn't.
We stood there.
And so if you go through the front door, we're going in.
And if you go to the back, we're not coming.
So you want to go in.
You got to go through the back door.
It turns the table so we're not feeding out of the back.
We're in that movie.
We stood there until lunch hour was over.
And then we decided to go back to our neighborhood.
And we were walking down the road when the sheriff.
I think there were maybe three people in the sheriff's department.
Deputy said, you're under arrest.
You broke a city audience.
And we started laughing.
Of course, we were bad kids.
And we started singing.
He marched us through town to the jail.
And nobody turned me around.
We got to keep on talking.
Walking.
No, we didn't call their names because we didn't know their names at that point.
We knew Sheriff Uppert.
We didn't know the other people.
We went to jail.
And they booked us and didn't lock the door.
He said, I'm not going to lock you up in here.
But you have to stay in the cell.
There were other prisoners in there.
So it was a good opportunity to say, you don't need to do crime.
We have other work to do out here.
So of course, we were all over the place.
And he made us go back to the cell.
It was kind of okay.
Go back in there until you leave.
And then we're going back out and talk to prisoners.
And at five o'clock, those of us who were under 18
were told to go home.
Anybody 18 and overhead to stay.
So I went home.
Walked home.
Were you worried when you kept putting your...
No.
I expected it.
Yeah, that's what happens.
You know kids all over the state were going to jail.
And so I went home.
We went...
I went back up.
I was headed back up to the jail the next day to take some ice water
for the kids.
A big jar.
And the sheriff pulled up and said, get in.
I know you're going to do something.
And took me back to jail.
Didn't lock up the cell.
Again, I'm roaming.
You know, having a good time, actually.
And that happened a few times.
And then when the kids who were over 18 had to go to trial,
the whole community turned out in Batesville.
Lots of people.
And some local people thought they could walk through the crowd
and hit the white kids who were there.
I think Chris Williams was in the group.
So when you say the white kid, you get the white volunteers.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, I do.
And Robert Miles, our local hero, decked him.
The guy who was going to go through the crowd to get Chris got hit
by Robert Miles.
The older people didn't buy the nonviolence, okay?
No, you hit me.
We're hitting you back.
Anyway, so Robert Miles was arrested
and people had to put up land to get to him.
We had a mass meeting that night.
I think at Mount Zion Church, which is closer to town.
And I don't remember what happened with the older kids
and when they went to court,
but the younger ones, we had to go to juvenile court.
And the lawyers were all busy all over the state
with other kids who had in jail for everything.
And they told us to ask for a continuance.
What is a continuance?
Okay, we'll ask.
And we did that.
And the judge said that if we kept doing stuff like we were doing,
we were going to have a record.
And when freedom comes, you're going to have a criminal record.
And I'm sitting there grinning.
As I always do, you said,
like that smile off your face.
So I wiped it off and threw it on the floor.
And my mother looked at me like,
you better behave yourself.
She's still worried.
Oh, yeah, she's worried.
They were both.
My stepfather also was worried.
That was over.
We didn't have to go back to jail for anything.
But one Saturday morning,
because we moved from the farm into town,
got a little house, a little bigger house.
Were they still farming?
Yeah, the farm was still there.
The mother was working at the local of the sundry.
Thomas Sundry in town.
My stepfather was going back to the farm to do farming.
I was a senior in high school by now.
But a knock came on our door one Saturday morning.
And my stepfather opened the door.
The deputy stepped in just as I was walking out of my room.
And he said, oh, wrong house.
And stepped back down.
And left.
And my stepfather said,
you're moving out of that room today.
And the shotguns came out.
Like he loaded the gun and put it in the corner like, oh no.
I did not get it you.
I didn't hear.
So.
So he assumed that the deputy was there to figure out
where I didn't shoot?
Yeah.
And they would be coming to you.
Did you think he was, did he?
Were you worried?
No.
I was too young and too silly to worry.
Did you think they might come?
I didn't think about it.
I really didn't.
My high school principal,
who was also a family.
After I had gone to the jail one day for something to visit
my old friends who were 18.
And somebody shocked, fired a gun.
And I ran back inside and said,
share a fuck with somebody just sat.
And he said, you had no business up here.
So okay.
The guy just ran and walked down the road
and the red pick up truck and there's a guy on the back
with a gun.
And he said, you had no business up here.
Okay.
I went home.
And the principal of my high school said,
if we can do anything to help let you know.
Really?
Yeah.
So I'm good.
I was.
You know?
But you feel you really have support in your community?
Yeah.
There was support in the community.
And one of the earlier stories before the 64 summer project,
I told you, the older people were not non-violent people.
We were having a voter registration meeting again at West Camp.
And they always left two people outside to guard.
And one of the men came in and said,
two men just came down here inquiring about what we're doing.
So I think we need to go home and get some protection.
Almost every woman in the church petted her purse.
Got mine right here.
And the response was, carry on.
No need to leave.
And it was just the way it was.
The women walked with pistols in their purses, even to church.
Did you get before the movement?
Yeah.
It's all the time.
It's in there.
And the men didn't know it?
They didn't tell them.
They didn't tell them how would they know.
They got to protect our families.
We don't know what's going to happen.
You know?
Did your mom do that?
Yeah.
My mom was a good shot.
They didn't teach me because they didn't think I had.
They were afraid to teach me.
My grandfather, yeah.
My grandfather, after I turned 18 and I had gone to the Delta to work with the farmer,
the farm workers down there said,
it's about time that you learned how to shoot.
And he took me out and put some bottles on the fence.
I was supposed to shoot them down.
Of course, I didn't love them.
I didn't learn.
You never learned?
No.
You weren't worried?
You didn't feel like you had to have your own pistol in your mouth?
I did.
I put a pistol in my purse in the late, in 1965.
Yeah.
But I didn't know how to shoot it.
It was just in there.
You were just open it by.
Did nobody would bother me?
Yeah.
That's right.
I remember.
You remember, were there any differences between the works that mandated and women did in
the movement or the way they participated?
I don't think so.
Not locally anyway.
Once you got to a different, after high school, let's go back to that a little bit.
I decided I got a scholarship and academic scholarship to Mississippi Industrial College.
Is it a private school?
No.
It was a private school run by some church group or the other.
It was in Holly Springs across the road from Rust.
I just took the test because I wanted to get away from school that day, so I took the test.
After high school and I applied, I wanted to go to Memphis State and then I heard that all
these people had walked off plantations in the Delta.
Farm workers.
And that's a state of life, right?
It probably was.
I don't remember, but probably.
Okay.
All of these people had walked off plantations in the Delta.
They said 1,000 people.
And I thought, oh, that's where I have to be.
I had no clue about anything.
I just turned 18.
The month before I graduated.
I went to a meeting at Mary Holmes College, reconnected to some of the people I met in 63,
and decided that I'm going to work in the movement full time.
Didn't occur to me that you have to have money or a place to live.
None of that.
I'm going.
So I went home from my week's meeting in Mary Holmes College and told my mother,
I'm not going to college yet.
I'm going to work in the movement.
And she couldn't believe it.
It's like, what do you mean?
I'm going to work in the movement.
There are 1,000 people walked off plantations in the Delta and I'm going to work with them.
And so, what could she do?
My older sister came to see me and she slipped me $10.
My bankroll.
You couldn't go to the putt, you couldn't go to the Delta with $10.
Yeah, that was what I had, $10.
That's the only one.
And I went to the Freedom Office.
It wasn't a sneak office, I don't think.
And I asked if anybody was driving down to Jackson and Lou Grant, who was head of the project at that time.
Yes, his name was Lewis Grant, we call them Lou.
He was driving down, so I said, can I get a ride? I'm going to Jackson.
I had made no connections.
Look, I had just turned 18.
I meant you don't get out of jail at 5 o'clock anymore.
You're now 18.
It's a little more serious.
So we went to Jackson to Mount Beulah, which was a conference center.
And we were getting ready for some major demonstration that I don't think I even knew about.
And I got a room for free, of course, and got my little blankets and sheets and went to get in my bed.
And some guy walked into the room.
There were no locks and got into the bed over there.
And I thought, ooh, you better get out of here.
Left my bag.
And saw somebody walking down the hallway.
And I went into the first room I saw on my left.
And there were three old women in there from Beatsville, my hometown.
I thought, oh my goodness, they said, girl, what are you doing here?
Are you here for the demonstration?
Uh-huh, yeah.
I'm here for the demonstration.
And they said, well, where are you staying?
I said, I have a room up the hall.
And they said, stay with us.
I said, okay.
Sounds good.
So I stayed with them overnight.
Got a ride into Jackson the next day with my little bag.
And I didn't have my $10 anymore.
I saw a dress that I wanted for seven, I bought it.
Just completely a child.
Went into Jackson to the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party office
and had my little bag with me.
And they were canvassing about the demonstration the next day.
And I pretended I knew the area.
I knew nothing about Jackson.
It was a city I came from a country.
So I helped somebody pass out leaflets in town
about the demonstration the next day.
Went back into the office.
Everybody was gone except one other woman who was from California.
And we were both sitting in the office on our bags.
And the last person to leave the office said, do you have someplace to stay?
And we both went, no.
And he said, well come and stay with me.
And so we picked up our bags and went with him.
He was living with a family in Jackson.
And we slept there.
And left our bags.
The next day went to the demonstration.
Was arrested about an hour in.
You know, maybe within the hour we were arrested.
And taken to the Jackson Fairgrounds.
And that's where all the old women I had seen from Batesville were.
Everybody, there were about a thousand women in there.
You know, I was in there for two weeks.
Met new people.
We didn't have clothes.
So somebody had a trench coat and we passed a trench coat around.
You can go take a shower.
You can wear a trench coat while you're taking your shower and washing your clothes.
You know, with ivory soap.
For years I couldn't stand the smell of ivory soap because of that.
You washed your clothes, you hung them up to dry with your somebody's trench coat on.
When they were dry, I almost dry you, put your clothes on and gave your trench coat to somebody else.
Uh-huh, two weeks.
You never heard that story?
Two weeks.
I mean I do about people being in the fairgrounds.
Oh, it was horrible.
Well, they gave us mattresses to sleep on the floor.
And at five o'clock in the morning you got up and stacked your mattress against the wall.
And went outside to eat your breakfast.
And there were fifty gallon tanks with fire under them.
And you had to wash your tray, dip it in the next one and the next one and put it down.
And hope it didn't get so hot you couldn't hold on to it because you knew they would make you stick your hands in this boiling water.
It was a little bit scary.
I don't remember what we ate.
It was something terrible.
Maybe syrup and grits.
A biscuit and grits.
They took all of the white women out and put them in the jail.
We stayed in the fairground.
And I remember there was one woman they didn't, they weren't sure.
And they said, ask her if she was colored or white.
And she said she didn't know.
And so they ended up taking her out and putting her in the jail with the white women.
But she was local?
No, no, she was not local.
Every day, you know your hands got kind of sore from sitting on concrete.
You walked around and talked to people about what they were doing in their communities.
I met a lot of folks my age.
I think I met June in there.
June Johnson after a couple of years, yeah, met her in the fairground.
What did you talk about what happened with her?
Not then, I don't think so.
I don't remember.
Mainly talking about what you're going to do when you get out.
And people that you do and what your experiences were.
And your towns where you grew up.
It was, it was very good in that sense.
And one morning, one of the women decided she wasn't giving up a mattress.
She stayed on the mattress.
And there was a police officer that we called red.
I don't know what his name was.
And he yelled for her to get up and she refused.
And he was going to hit her with his belly club.
And she took the belly club.
And she said, I think it was a sick woman.
I think poor red guy, his leg broken.
But it was a standoff between all of these women and the police.
They had guns and their hands on their belly clubs.
And we're just standing there.
You know, cursing, I let some of my best words in there.
And there was a little, I don't know what you call it,
a little line between us.
And a lady from Batesville, Mrs. Thelma Glover,
walked in the middle of the little line
and started praying and swinging her arms.
And by the time she finished praying, they had all backed out.
We were saved again.
Yeah.
Were you worried?
I thought it was the funniest thing I'd ever seen in my life.
I couldn't wait to tell it.
Hadoota was one of my best friends about how your mom stood out in the middle of everybody.
We were cursing at the cops and calling them names.
And she steps out and start praying and swinging her arm.
And they backed out of the room.
It was funny.
No, I wasn't worried.
I guess I was a little crazy.
I didn't think about worrying.
Then two weeks later, they called my name.
They were calling names and somebody had bells me out.
And I went back to the house where I had stayed before we were arrested.
Oh, and by the way, the woman had sent some underwear or something from the suitcase to us
because she found ID in the woman from California's bag.
I didn't have any.
She sent us a change of clothes because her sister was a cop,
which was interesting.
Yeah.
Were there black officers?
Well, they were a black woman officer, her sister.
I don't know if there were others.
I didn't know that.
For that time in that, I guess.
It was 65.
You know they had all the protests in 1962 over high.
The man who was hiring.
Yeah, I think there was a black...
I don't know how many black women were on the police force, but that one came.
And we were sitting in the woman's house.
She was a beautician.
She saw us and closed the shop.
She took us to a house and we could take a real bath and warm water and eat real food.
And she was just very sweet.
And the next day we slept in a bed, not on the concrete floor with a little thin mattress.
Next day, we were sitting there and the California woman said,
that looks like a SNCC person.
And it was my friend, Hollis Watkins.
And one of the lawyers had remembered my name because it was a little different.
And he found us somehow.
But how was this?
Yeah.
How did you know Hollis?
From 1963.
From the beginning of January?
Yeah, 1963.
And we stayed in touch loosely.
And so I went with Hollis to McComb, Mississippi.
And McComb was one of those hot places, scary.
And I was a little nervous about McComb.
Other places I knew.
You know, Batesville was mild compared to there.
And I met Curtis Hayes.
Curtis is now Curtis, my homie.
Curtis was putting together a group of Mississippi kids to work in the Delta, just what I needed.
So I went up after a couple of days in McComb.
I went with Curtis up to Cleveland, Mississippi.
And Cleveland was one of the places where the Mississippi Freedom Labor Union was organized.
Shaw was near Cleveland.
And had no idea what you do to organize anything or anybody except my experiences in Batesville.
And I stayed with Owen Brooks initially, because the National Council of Churches was paying the stipend for Freedom Corps.
And I was going to be a part of that group.
And when you talked about the difference in men and women, Freedom Corps was mainly guys and me.
Guys and me.
You know why?
No, I have no idea.
So you could throw a fan of course in the Delta Ministry from the National Council of Churches.
So they were recruiting young people in Mississippi to be the Freedom Corps?
Curtis did.
Uh huh.
And we paid for by a Delta Ministry.
Yeah.
And we got $10 a week.
And of course, I was filling my 18.
I'm not an adult person because I'm 18.
And I'm staying with Owen Brooks, who is working for the Delta Ministry.
And Owen was funny.
I thought he was an old man.
He was about 30, I guess.
And I went out one night with a group of movement people to a Duke joint, a Rexburg,
where they were playing live blues, loved blues, and stayed out all night.
Got back the next day, I'm 18, remember.
I'm an adult person.
I can stay out all night if I want to.
I said to myself, Owen was like a mother in.
He said, you stay out all night again.
And I will call your mother.
Where have you been?
I told them the story didn't work.
Owen found a family for me to stay with.
He wasn't going to be responsible for young Juadine leaving Batesville for the first time, trying to hang out, have no clue about anything.
So I stayed with the Washington family.
And not anymore.
Not anymore.
So I went to live with the Washington family for a minute or two.
And then they sent me off to Rosedale, you know, one of the places where the Freedom Labor Union was really big.
And a lot of the farm workers had lived in the little town.
And I was to organize and work with them.
I lived with a family there, Frank Davis, who was the local leader.
And it was interesting because he lived right across the road, or the street from the courthouse and the jail.
And I stayed in the room with their daughter, who was, I think, a 14-year-old.
And they had three other people living in their house.
Now, house was tiny.
Morton Thomas from Boston, I think, and a student at Harvard.
Billy Kochiyama, who was Japanese grew up in Harlem.
And we'll stay another person.
Maybe that was it.
So these guys are people who came in and this is it?
Yes.
What about the rest of the Freedom Court when they came outside or local?
They were local.
Everybody was in the movement at home.
And I think that's our Reese Webb from my county.
He's still there.
Homer Crawford, Willie had been a farm worker.
He was a tractor driver, I think.
Isaac Foster, who had been a tractor driver on somebody's plantation.
And Joe Harrison from Holmes County.
Did you think about the fact that the other Freedom Court
and the outside folks are mostly men?
No.
Did you notice?
Yeah, I noticed.
I had to fight them sometime, you know?
But I could curse as good as they could, so.
No, they would.
They said nothing to do with the movement.
There was a softball game.
I played softball.
And Benjamin Brown.
You said you don't want to get killed in the city?
Yes, yes he did.
Ben said, why don't you act like other girls?
And I said just because you can't play softball is not my problem.
I'm playing first base.
And I played first base.
I'm studying about that.
Not at all.
And then I recruited another young woman, Helen Williams,
from Rosedale, to come and work with us.
And then another woman I met in Washington at one of those demonstrations,
Tete Tete came and joined the group.
Helen could hang.
Tete, not so much.
And Faye, my home girl, my best friend, came and worked with us for a minute.
She also couldn't hang.
Mr. Boy's, well boys, you know?
He can only.
Did they just find out that it really is?
No, no.
And we had, when we went out to the plantations to talk to farm workers,
we left one person in the van.
We had a van.
And when you saw the dust coming, you knew the owner was coming.
So you had to beep the horn.
And everybody ran out from wherever they were and jumped in the car and we took off.
And the fight was on.
Like, they were chasing us and we were chased.
We just ran.
That's all.
And then we would go back.
And sometimes when we went back, there were the people who were gone.
They had left overnight.
It was like slavery.
They lived there.
They shopped there.
They went to church there.
There was one plantation, Delta Pines.
It had seven churches.
I counted them.
Yeah.
And people had no reason to leave.
So there's a few people who have cloned off on the stage.
Yeah.
And so when you went back and knocked on the door that you had knocked on last week
other day before and nobody was there, you knew they had run away.
Right away, sort of, when you saw a safe lift in the room?
No.
Together away.
The different life.
When you say you're working and organizing, it's a farm labor party.
What was freedom labor union?
You know, I'm trying to take a weird, I've got the freedom labor union.
I think the former labor party was a big deal.
At the time, okay.
At the time people were making 30 cents an hour, ten hour days, three dollars a day.
And what we were saying is they needed to make more money and organizing.
And that they should walk off if they couldn't get more money.
Because they couldn't live on three dollars a day.
They were on the plantations mainly because they had accumulated bills with the company store, you know, to eat.
And they couldn't leave because they had a debt.
They had to pay.
Could pay the debt.
So that was in Bolivar County, Sunflower County, and Washington counties.
And I also tried to organize a little bit of a little tiny freedom school.
Because a lot of the kids had dropped out at third grade to teach people how to write their names.
You know, simple stuff.
Billy, Kotiama, his family had lived in Harlem.
His parents had been in internment camps during World War II.
And when they were released, they moved to Harlem.
And his mom was a big follower of Malcolm X.
And Billy was the first person who told me I was African-American.
I think he called us Afro-American at the time.
He was like, okay, we can be that.
Billy also was not your typical non-violent movement person.
I went out of town for some meeting of the other.
I got back to town and they said, got to go to court at two o'clock.
Billy was arrested over the weekend.
I was like, okay, I got my $10, right?
Billy had been standing with one of the kids when the clan marched through town.
And one of the clansmen, we're talking about the KKK now, called him Tojo.
That was his behind. Billy kicked his behind right there and was arrested.
I used my $10 to get Billy out of jail or to keep him out of jail.
I think that was the fine 10 bucks good thing because we didn't have one in that.
Billy went back to New York at the end of the summer.
And I didn't ever see Billy again.
It was over. I met his mom a few years later.
It was kind of a nice, raggedag crew in Rose Del.
So did you bring up or get farmers to organize and walk off?
There were a lot of people who walked off, but they had walked off with no means of support.
Labor unions, freedom labor union had no money.
I think Isaac Foster, one of the guys who worked with Freedom Corps,
was one of the organizers of the Freedom Labor Union.
It didn't really know how unions worked.
I wish I could remember details.
I know there was a group of them living in tents in the year Greenville.
Oh, that was later.
Greenville Air Force Base sent me to raise money for people.
Two Minnesota and to Pennsylvania.
It was my first plane ride.
I was scared to death, but I had to put on a brave front.
And...
Were you not worried about anything in the specific, but you're afraid of an airplane?
Yes. Absolutely.
And I got to speak at little church groups and stuff in Minnesota and in Pennsylvania.
And Illinois.
And this was also, I guess, it was late 65 or early 66.
I went with Bob Reverend Robert Beach.
We called him Bob Beach.
And I was kind of fun.
I was excited when you watched you.
It was different.
Yeah, yeah.
In Minnesota, there were a couple of women who had been in Greenville working for Delta Ministry.
And so I stayed with them.
So I knew them.
The church groups, you know, I guess they had never seen somebody like me before.
And that was kind of interesting.
They were just sort of staring.
At one church, they had me put on a robe.
And you know, with the preachers, and I stood there.
And did my little talk.
Yeah.
I thought so too.
Okay, I'll put it on our own care.
And most of the groups were white.
When I went to Pennsylvania, and I'm just outside of Pittsburgh,
I asked the minister that I was living with.
I didn't know whether we were black or colored then.
Other people who like me nearby, because I hadn't seen any.
And so he arranged with the NAACP for me to come and speak in the Hill District.
So really?
Yeah, yeah.
That's cool.
And one of the women said, where are you staying while you're here?
And I said Mount Lebanon.
She said, oh my goodness girl.
It's a wonder we don't have seen you hung up on a tree out there.
Like, are you serious?
She said, yep.
It's about the North.
Yeah.
It was revelation.
It was like black people don't go out there after dark.
And I don't know that we were black yet.
But you know, you don't go out there after dark.
Oh, that's why I leave before sign up and go back after dark care.
Okay.
And then...
They were worried, but they're like, you shouldn't...
Yeah.
It was like, okay.
I didn't know that.
And then I think the next stop was Illinois.
And I spoke at the seminary in Chicago.
I don't remember the name, McCormick maybe.
I don't know.
But I think that's where I was speaking.
Uh-huh.
And they told me I had a family for me.
And I said, I have family here.
I began...
Up the river.
So they had to take me to the south side and I had to yell up in the tentimate for my older sister to come and get me downstairs to let me in.
And I was speaking at a church there on Sunday.
Did you been in Chicago before?
No.
And my sister did not like the way I looked.
You cannot go out of this house looking like that.
So she straightened my hair and put me on a suit with hills.
I thought they will not recognize me.
This is not me.
And I allowed it because you didn't...
You had to respect your elders.
That was how I grew up, you know?
Okay.
I haven't noticed you speaking of respect in your elders the last time.
Well, I had trouble with that.
Yeah.
That's a lot of thinking.
I had trouble with it.
So you said your sister will understand your hair.
She did. She didn't want to. She did it.
So were you wearing your hair natural on purpose because of the cement?
Yeah.
Did all the women in the movement?
No, I don't think so.
I met some young woman named Gwen Gillian, I think.
And she had her hair natural.
And I thought that's not so bad.
And then I saw an album cover with Odetta on it with natural hair.
I hadn't cut my hair yet, but I said,
I don't need to straighten my hair. Why would I do that?
Mm-hmm.
But my sister wasn't having it.
So I went back to Mississippi and something was happening,
the politics of the movement I think was changing early 1966.
You just cut that or talked about it.
I don't really remember. I wish.
The Freedom Corps was kind of breaking up.
I don't remember why.
But...
What are the racial conflicts?
Freedom Corps was all black.
It was Curtis and us.
If you were working with some of the white kids...
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
I don't remember that.
I have to try and remember what happened because I blocked on it.
But I left my place in Bolivar County.
I was living with the family there who had absolutely nothing.
I slept with some of the kids.
You could be sitting in the bed and see a mouse running across the pillow.
I can't handle this.
The floor is one thing.
The pillow?
Yeah. It's time to move.
I went to Jackson.
And I don't remember what went into that decision.
Helen decided to go back home to Rosedale.
I went to Jackson.
The guys also split up.
I don't remember what caused the split.
And I'll send a note to Curtis and ask him if he remembers.
In Jackson, I stayed with another group of movement women in the patio apartments where other
snick people lived.
For some of the people you were staying with said...
The women in that apartment was Gracie Hartthorn from Hattiesburg, Joyce Brown from McComb, Marjorie Hyatt.
Marjorie was from Hattiesburg and she also claimed Pittsburgh somehow.
And most of them worked for the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party in the office.
And I wasn't sure what I was doing yet.
And Smith always pulled me out.
And I did.
So I went to work for Frank.
He had neighborhood development group or something.
And they were supposed to make bricks to build homes for people in strike city.
That's what the tent city was called, strike city.
And I was working in his office and getting a feel for the city.
It was...
Where was strike city?
It was Strike City, Mississippi.
And it's where people went when they went on strike with the...
When they got kicked off plantations.
Yeah, it was a tent city and they had a big sign in [/at] Strike City.
Isaac Foster, the person I mentioned earlier, was one of the people from strike city.
Did you meet Jean Wheeler at that time?
She and Frank were married.
I met her with Frank.
I think they were already married.
And she was like a big sister to me.
Yeah.
We still live in the same neighborhood.
What can I tell you?
Yeah.
Was she still organizing, working with the movement at that time?
Yes.
But she was working, I think, mainly with Frank.
And his brick factory idea, trying to figure out how you make bricks to build houses.
I'm trying to remember.
Jean, I think, was also writing, which I thought was interesting.
Yeah.
And I had to think about, now it's almost time to go to college.
You've almost finished your year of movement work.
And how are you going to do that?
I don't know.
And some guy came into the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party office and was looking for people recruiting for Bishop College in Texas.
It was a Baptist college.
And most of us went.
All of us who had finished high school, yeah, we'll go, what do we need to do?
And we went to Bishop.
So Bishop was actively recruiting movement kids?
No.
Bishop was not.
Tom Brown, who had been a SNCC person, was working in the admissions office.
He was recruiting movement folks without telling them that.
No.
Not Bishop.
Absolutely not.
No.
So Marjorie Hyatt, Linda Wilson, who was active in Hattiesburg,
and I, who else?
Maybe it was just three of us went to Bishop.
Mm-hmm.
You all organized a Bishop for Bishop?
Oh, it was a nightmare.
Bishop was an experience.
When we got to Dallas, I think we took a bus there.
The person from the school who came to pick us up had a big sign on the side of the car.
The said repent and be saved.
Did you turn the leaf in?
If I could have, I think I would have, I was, oh my.
Okay.
And so I went to, we got to the campus and I had an afro body and had cut my hair.
Low and all the little women girls were staring like, look, she washed her hair.
Like, oh, now I know what black kids feel like when they go to white schools.
Had a roommate who was very religious, I guess, young.
And thought this is a mistake, but they didn't try to pair us with each other.
They wanted us to, I guess, stretch out.
Went to breakfast the next morning, same thing happened.
Everybody stopped eating to stare like she washed her hair.
So that was interesting.
I had to get a job.
I was in the work study program and I got a job.
They put me in the laundry room.
We had nobody with CME.
And so I wouldn't mess with nobody's hair.
I'm sorry, it's straightened.
Did any of the house mothers of the dean of students, did they say anything to you about your hair?
The librarian said something to me about my hair.
She said, you look as bad as that African woman who came here with her hair like that.
Jamella Stokes from Hadisburg said to her, I've never seen anybody born with blue hair before.
And that was when black women who had white hair would dye it blue.
And she sort of lifted me because I got fired from my first job.
First thing I did, and it wasn't an act of protest or anything.
I put it in this roller thing that was supposed to dry it.
It never came out.
And the room got all smoky.
It burned.
So they sent me out of there and sent me to the library to work in periodical.
So nobody would see me.
I could be behind the books and behind the magazines and all of that.
That was kind of interesting.
The other interesting part I think was the first night, not the first night, the second night.
A couple of kids came up to stairs and said, can you do my hair like that?
Interesting.
I said, yeah, I got to do this wash it now.
I cut it for you.
I cut hair.
Did I pull up out cutting hair?
No, but I could do it.
So you started a movement.
I think everybody was ready pretty much.
And Ebony magazine did a cover in 1966 that said, all natural.
And they had women on the cover with afros.
Oh, was my mother pleased.
See, why Dean's not the only one, look.
That's cool.
So once Ebony did it, it was all right, though.
People...
It took a little bit more time.
Mm-hmm.
And how would university, maybe that was later,
the queen of how it had an afro, but people were getting used to the idea of, okay, you can have that be hair.
So did you, you stay at Bishop?
I stayed at No.
I stayed at Bishop for two years.
And I had a good time at Bishop.
I made friends.
It was like being in elementary school again in some ways, because it was a very strict campus.
You couldn't wear slacks.
It was a religious school.
It was a Baptist college.
I got caught.
You were supposed to go to chapel every, I think, three days a week.
And I would send my punch card by one of the girls on the dorm.
And I would sit in my room and tinker on the guitar.
And one day I got a knock on the door.
And I thought it was somebody else who had cut chapel.
And it was the dean of women.
And she went back in the house.
There was a young lady in her room playing the ukulele.
And everybody knew it was me.
So, okay.
And on Sundays, when you were supposed to go to church, I went to the federal prison.
There was a prison nearby called Seagoville.
And my English professor had given me something that a prisoner over there had written.
And I thought he was a good writer.
So, we connected.
They arranged for me to come and visit.
So, that's where I went on Sundays.
And I wrote, when you had to sign out the dorm, I said I was going to a Quaker meeting.
They didn't know.
So, they would let you do a Quaker meeting instead of chapel?
Yeah, that was chapel for me.
But I was gone.
And there was a woman.
I think she was from Louisiana, whose fiance was in prison there because he refused to go to the war.
She would pick me up on Sunday mornings and take me with her.
And I would go visit Lafayette, Locke, the prisoner.
And I also was able to get books and stuff for them that they wanted.
And he would tell me where to leave it, like in the pastor near the prison.
I don't know how they got them.
And I would, you know?
Interesting.
That's how I spent my Sundays instead of going to church.
What did you do when you left Bishop?
After Bishop.
Oh gosh.
I left Bishop in 68.
And Dr. King was coming to Batesville to speak before his death.
And of course it would be before his death.
But my mom said, Dr. King is coming to town.
You need to go see him.
And I said no.
I was depressed.
I'm not going to see him.
And so she did what she normally did.
She got my uncle and said, go get Juadine and take her to see Dr. King.
Is this for brother?
Yes, yes.
So I'm sitting in the house and I'm not going outside.
And my uncle shows up and he said, put your clothes on.
We're going to see Dr. King.
Okay.
You don't say no to your uncle.
And that might have been a male thing too.
You know?
He's the man in the house.
And he's an elder.
You have to listen kind of.
So I went with him to see Dr. King.
And Dr. King had young people with him and I was surprised.
It's like, I thought this was all old preachers.
What is this?
You know?
And I don't know.
The turning of the floor.
Yeah.
In 1966, the Meredith March, he had been one of the people who came at the end.
And he spoke at the rally.
I can't say that I listened.
But he spoke.
I heard his voice.
And people turned out in Batesville.
And there were just massive numbers of people there to hear Dr. King.
Which I thought was annoying again.
It was like, okay.
It's 1968.
But what it had done is exposed me that I was back in town.
And my friend, Tate, who had come from Washington and worked with Freedom Corps a little bit showed up at our house in like two weeks' time.
And I was going to say, I heard you were here.
And we were organizing the Poor People's Campaign.
That might have happened after King's assassination.
King was assassinated shortly after that.
Maybe the next couple of weeks.
And coming to help us organize for the Poor People's Campaign.
And I thought, that's silly.
Just going to Washington to March and Bade.
But okay.
And I went with her to Memphis.
Stayed at the Lorraine Motel where King had been assassinated.
And met these younger people who were working with SCLC.
And agreed that I would go and help them get folks on the buses to come to DC.
But I wasn't coming.
I went to Grenada and worked with this young guy named Leon Hall who was organizing for SCLC.
And once they got people all signed up to get on the buses to come to DC, I went to Mount Beulah.
And I was supposed to go back to Batesville.
I didn't really have any plans.
Like, what are you going to do now?
I don't know.
And Leon said, okay, go with us to Selma and then you can go home.
And I said, okay.
And went to Selma.
Some little kid in Selma said, can you stay with us?
And I said, sure.
He went and asked his mom.
And I spent the night at their house.
Next day, they said, come with us to Montgomery.
And then you can go home.
I stayed with Leon's family in Montgomery.
Come with us to Birmingham.
And then you can go home.
And I ended up in Washington.
And that's with the Poor People's Campaign.
With the Poor People's Campaign.
Yes.
So, was that the Mule Train?
Yeah.
That's the Mule Train.
Ended up in Washington, DC.
But was it like to travel with the Mule Train?
Hmm.
One of the interesting things, the Mule Train, I wasn't so much into.
But one of the things that happened, I think, in Birmingham, is I met these reporters
from the New York Times and the Washington Post.
That Earl called well, Gerald Fraser, he just died.
Thomas A. Johnson, with the [New York] Times of the New York Times, and Robert C. "Bob" Maynard from the Washington Post,
they were interesting.
So, I kind of hung out with them and listened to what they were doing.
And thought, hmm, interesting work.
Hmm.
Okay.
I think that was more interesting to me than trying to organize people to come to Washington
to sit in the tent city".
You said that you didn't really see the point of going to Washington to buy some bags?
Yeah.
What were you doing?
We have to figure a way to do it ourselves now.
Washington is not listening.
And I don't know when I came to that conclusion, but I had come to that conclusion.
I had come here, I think, in 1965, to help unseat the Mississippi delegation.
And we lobbied and set out in front of the Capitol all night and went home and nothing happened.
Same thing had happened in 1964, you know, with the Mississippi Freedom Democratic Party going to Atlantic City.
And I didn't know for sure what we needed to do, but I thought we had to do something different than marching and begging.
I think that's where I was.
So in DC, Washington, I made it to Washington and they had put up tents on the National Mall.
And SCLC staff, oh, this is terrible, I didn't had rooms at the Pitts Motor Inn".
So the four people are staying in tents on the mall, and the staff, and then the hotel?
Yes.
I mean, the hotel too.
Did you think about that?
Of course I did.
I thought, you know, what a difference. What kind of thing are you doing here?
You have people living out here in mud because it was a muddy place.
And we are all sitting up in the pit smoder in, eating, and sleeping, warm, warm showers.
It's something unfair about this situation.
So I don't know how long I had been here, but one day we were driving down 14th Street.
I was with one of the preachers.
And this would have been after 14th Street, after the riots?
Yeah, this was 68th, after the riots.
And I see Charles E. Cobb Jr.
And I said to the preacher, pull over!
And he pulled over and I jumped out of the car and hugged Charlie.
And he told me that everybody is in Washington.
I said, you're kidding.
And he said, no, and I said, I'm out at what was it called?
Resurrection City with the preachers.
We need to do something.
We need to organize these people or do something.
And he said, where are you staying?
And I said to pits, motor in.
And he said, okay, and it was before a cell phone, so there was no way to call.
Went back to that place.
Resurrection City.
And did whatever we did.
I think I was supposed to be working with volunteers or something.
But I have vague recollection of what we did out there,
other than looking at people stumping around through mud and getting ready to go through demonstrations,
watching around the Department of Agriculture or something.
Do not have a very good image of that.
That evening I went back to the pits and Curtis, I think, came.
Curtis and his wife, Mimi, were here.
And he said, what are you doing?
And I said, I'm out in the mud with the people at Resurrection City.
He said, okay.
And the next day Frank showed up.
And he said, get your stuff.
Let's go.
You're getting out of here.
And I got my little bags.
And I left the pits, motor in in Resurrection City and the poor people's campaign.
And I had an apartment with a roommate.
And I became a student at the Institute for Policy Studies.
He was really?
Getting a little stifled.
Yes.
And going over there.
At the Institute?
Yes.
Frank Smith, Marvin Holloway, Ivanhoe Donaldson, were fellows at the Institute.
And I was a student.
I was Frank's student.
And I would go to seminars.
And I mainly went to the seminars, I think, to eat.
I don't know that that's true, but that's probably true.
And then shortly after that, somebody quit work at Drum and Spear Bookstore.
So I got a job at Drum and Spear Bookstore.
What was that like at the time?
Oh, it was wonderful.
I guess not everybody else would say what Drum and Spear Bookstore was started, I guess, by Charlie.
And a group called Afro-American Resources.
And it was every book in the world you could find about black people.
And I had never seen that many books about black people.
And I tried to read as many of them as I could.
So when people walked into the store and I'm looking for a book about such and such, I can say, look over here.
This book is wonderful.
It has, so that was my first real job, I guess, outside of the movement, but it was not really outside of the movement.
It was Drum and Spear Bookstore.
It was wonderful.
It was connected later with the Center for Black Education.
They were off-shoot of Federal City College.
A lot of the guys from the movement was teaching over there, black history, kind of stuff.
And I didn't go to the center a lot.
I mainly stayed at the bookstore.
And then there was a radio program on Sunday nights, Sauti ya Watoto.
Did you spell it?
Oh, please.
I wouldn't.
Okay.
Is that why he was?
Yeah.
And we did Mimi Curtis' former wife with do scripts from stories, regular stories.
And we would read them on the air on Sunday nights, Sunday nights, and take on the characters.
That was fun.
And you got authors coming to the bookstore to sign their books and to talk.
And I remember one Saturday I wasn't there, Lerone Bennett Jr, who wrote before the Mayflower,
was in the store signing books when the police tear gased the bookstore.
What?
Tear gased it.
Shot tear gas into the store.
What was there?
I don't know.
I have no idea.
It was very strange.
It was Lerone Bennett Jr, the historian.
After that, I think we were always on the radar because it was old movement people in the bookstore.
We moved to a bigger place because people were ordering books from all over the country coming into the store,
doing their book signings and stuff.
So it expanded.
Ralph Featherstone, who had been an organizer in Mississippi, came to be the manager of the store.
Yeah, he was.
He was first Tony Gittens, then Featherstone.
So it became a little bit more political, I think.
People came into the store to talk and to get books and to tell us about books that they thought we should have.
It was one of the biggest, I guess, black bookstores in the country at the time.
Did you feel like this movement worked?
Yeah, actually.
Yeah, I did.
What was the thought of the answer to that question you had been asking about what to do instead of protesting?
No, not really, but it was something to do at the time.
We moved to a bigger place, meeting new people.
Then the day that two days after we moved to this bigger location, Featherstone was blown up in a car with [Che] Payne.
And we probably should have had some kind of psychological counseling, but we didn't, you know.
That was 1970, March 10th.
I didn't do very well with it, but Mimi, Curtis' former wife, had guessed money.
Did I get a job first?
Yes, I left the bookstore.
I went to work for the (likely) Black Child Development Institute, downtown DC, where you had to actually put on clothes.
You actually put on clothes to go to work.
You didn't wear your jeans and stuff.
And Met Florence Tate, who was like a big sister.
I got a job as a receptionist.
I had never had a job outside of the movement, a movement people before.
And I couldn't type really well.
I had taken typing in high school on a royal typewriter.
I had this new typewriter, and I'm over there making noise, pretending I'm typing while people are there and answering the phones.
And when they left to go home, I would do my work.
I would type the letters.
I should have been typing during the day.
So, is that because you didn't want people to know that I couldn't type?
Yeah, that was part of the job.
So I had to do my work.
So I would stay.
I'd get home at about 10 o'clock every night.
And then the head of the organization had some kind of black caucus meeting.
And she came in at lunchtime, and she needed me to type what she was saying.
And I was typing away, and she looked over and saw that I was on the paper.
And she sat down to the typewriter and typed her own work.
And went back to her meeting, and when she came back, she said,
how have you been getting out all of this work?
I said, when you go home in the evenings, I do my work.
And she said, I don't want you staying here late anymore.
I was also rewriting people.
I don't want you staying here late.
I'm going to get somebody to come in to do the work that you haven't finished and help you with your typing.
And I said, oh, okay, I wasn't fired.
I was now, I think I became a program analyst or something.
So I could do a little writing, rewriting, and typing at my own pace.
And that was a three month project.
When that was over, we went off to the West Indies.
First to Haiti, no Puerto Rico first, with Judy and Mimi.
Puerto Rico first, then to Haiti, and then to Trinidad.
That's Judy Richardson?
Yeah, Barbados.
We were gone for a minute.
So this is like, we're going to go and see these places explore?
I think so, but I think it was also a mental health issue that we didn't ever talk about.
It was really good.
It was a good trip.
Haiti I loved.
And one of the things that somebody said is when you get off the plane, say what you want to do while you're here, somebody will hear you.
And I said, I want to go to a voodoo ceremony.
And about three days in, and then another guy, old man came and said, I take care of you girls.
And he grabbed our stuff and took us off to the hotel where we were supposed to stay.
He argued with the manager, we left there and went to another hotel because he didn't like what the guy was charging us or something.
He actually did take care of us.
About three days in, some man came and said, I came to take you to the voodoo.
He said, you want to go to the voodoo?
Yeah.
He took us.
Yeah, it was amazing.
I was so scared I didn't know what to do with myself.
I didn't know what to expect.
And all of a sudden you're hearing these drums and these people are singing something you don't know what they're saying.
And I'm scared.
Okay.
We left there finally and I prayed.
This was the time.
Well, please don't go back with us.
I don't know what they were saying.
I promise you I won't come back.
You mentioned the drums.
And earlier, I think before we started the interview, you said that there was drumming in Canola County.
Northern Mississippi.
Yeah.
And Panolla County, yes.
Can you tell us about that?
A little bit.
I didn't know a lot at the time.
Two days, every July, third and fourth, there were these old men who played drums.
And the first thing you heard on the third was a big, big boom, a boom sound.
And it was like, you knew the drums were there.
You got new clothes to go to the event.
A baseball team came to play baseball with the neighborhood guys against the neighborhood guys.
We got our new clothes and we went to the picnic.
That's what it was called and everybody came.
These old men had a fire going to heat the drums, the skins on the drum.
And they played and only the men danced to it.
The women were making...
No.
The women were cooking.
The kids were dancing to the jukebox when the old men stopped playing.
And it was like, will they hurry up and finish?
I was embarrassed because my stepfather danced, so did his brother.
You know it was like, oh, they're so embarrassing.
And they came every July, third and fourth, two days.
And everybody came.
I mean, the whole neighborhood turned out.
For the baseball game first and then the drumming in the evening,
had no idea it was African.
No idea.
And then, some years ago, one of my girlfriends who had come to work with us in Freedom Corps for a second,
so do you remember the drums?
Those old men playing drums and I said, yeah, they had five flute made from cane.
I said, yeah, and I went online and looked for them and found them.
The Smithsonian recorded them in the 1940s.
Trace the rhythms that they were playing back to West Africa, Mali.
And I said, oh, my goodness, we were doing that then and I had no clue.
That's the thing, isn't it?
Uh-huh, then I asked one of my cousins, did you ever go to the picnics and he said, yeah, I went.
Everybody went.
Uh-huh, so it was like a neighborhood gathering for two days.
Did they play in other places?
Yeah, all over northern Mississippi.
So you all got them for the Fourth of July?
And third, the third and fourth, uh-huh.
But they would play in other places.
Yeah.
Uh-huh.
Alan Lomax wrote that the women in other parts of the state saluted the drums.
We didn't do that.
We didn't know.
Well, you know, and that they killed slotted goats and served goat sandwiches.
We didn't do all of that.
We had the normal, you know, picnic food.
You can buy a fish sandwich and sow this.
And did they still do it?
The drummers.
the granddaughter of Othar Turner was supposed to hold the group together.
I haven't seen them since, and I promised one of my cousins that I was going to look for the recordings,
because the younger people do not know about it, you know?
Everybody moved away from the farms, and the older people didn't share.
It didn't tell us what was going on.
So, um, was the Turner?
Othar Turner came after Sid Hemphill.
They have a, um, a statue or a plaque or something to him in northern Penole County.
And so it is a someplace like that.
Because I believe his grandfather and a group played at this messoing in football.
I heard that.
I didn't know it, so I missed them.
I would have gone.
I would have danced.
That's what we're looking for.
We're looking for the 40s, though.
And so, yeah, but I think they have a recording.
I know they have a recording.
I don't know if it's online, from the more recent ones.
Mm-hmm.
I have a record called Penole even played County plays.
Are you serious?
That's what we're talking about.
Oh, please do.
I don't know.
Oh, please.
I'll do the basement.
Oh, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I wanted to ask, um, I want to go back if it's okay.
Yeah.
And I'm still stuck on the fact that you're in church and you're supposed to play amazing grace.
And you come out with, uh, old freedom.
Yeah.
It was wonderful.
I lived.
I only know of one person who protested very strongly.
And I've since seen her and sort of made peace with her.
And I was like, this girl has lost her mind.
But it was also after I was almost 18 and I stopped playing at the church after I graduated
high school because I left.
And didn't have to do it anymore.
So by the time you do this, the movement is really kind of big and put a family of a lot of people
into it.
They know it, but that's not what you do in church unless it's a mass meeting where you're singing
freedom songs.
You're mixing it.
And what your mom say.
Nothing.
She didn't tell me I better not do it again or any of that.
She didn't.
My friends did the choir.
We knew the songs.
We knew.
I don't think so.
I think I just did it.
And the choir was mostly my friends that I had been with since I was 10.
You know.
So we knew what to do with each other.
But did the minister want to do movement supporters?
No.
I don't remember him ever mentioning anything about the movement.
Can he didn't say nothing to you?
No.
Nobody did.
Yes.
The Deacon, after that meeting that we had at church with the record, they started locking the church.
And the Deacon went around to the different houses saying your children are getting involved with this stuff and you better talk to them because I'm not getting them out of jail
and they don't know if they get arrested.
He went from house to house.
But by the time 1964 rolled around, he actually kept in his house a couple of the volunteers.
So people were moving in the direction of the movement?
Yes.
Yeah.
So you weren't allowed to use the church for meetings after that?
Well, I got up.
We had something called, what was the thing called?
All the requires got together to sing one Sunday a month from different churches.
And I think I did get up and announce that they had locked out church and we could no longer meet there.
And I did it.
It wasn't completely innocent.
And somebody from West Camp got up and said, our church is always open to you.
If you need to meet, you can meet here.
Did you do that to him?
Yeah.
I think we went to West Camp once, but it was not in the neighborhood and you had to get a ride.
Although a group of a 16-year-old Mrs. Glover let us use her car.
Her daughter, who was my age, could drive us anyplace.
We would even drive off to Memphis to get a 5-cent adog.
How old were you all from Memphis?
59 miles.
So it's like the big city.
Oh, yeah.
It was the city.
What was greener like when you went in there in 63 for that week?
Can you describe the community at all?
It was mostly movement people that I saw.
We went to eat at somebody's house who invited us over for dinner.
That was good.
It seemed to be much more active than Batesville was at the time.
You know, like I said, after Medgar Evers was killed, there was a mass meeting.
And the church was packed and people were out on the streets.
You know, the people who couldn't get in.
I had never seen that before.
So it was a movement city, a town.
Mm-hmm.
Other people that you met that stand out was like,
some of the two who's being there, like Joyce Ladner?
No.
Freddie Green was there.
Yeah.
Freddie was there.
Freddie's family is from Greenwood.
And she was a student at Dillard.
I think she was a freshman.
And my cousin was a freshman at Mississippi Valley State.
So they got to know each other.
And then I ran into Freddie, you know, over and over again after that.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
I know Mr. Vile was one of the really important leaders.
Absolutely.
Can you tell us what he was like?
He lived right down the road from us before my mom got remarried.
Very strong man.
He had a farm.
I knew his sons, the two older sons, Vincent and Robert Jr. miles.
Everybody knew that he was a movement man.
He was a member of West Camp Missionary Baptist Church.
And he looked after us, like when my mom was at work and we were tear down the two rooms.
One night we were playing church.
And Robert Miles knocked on the door because he heard all the noise.
To check on us, mother was at work until 8 o'clock, you know.
And we fell all in the floor and tried to crawl under the beds because it scared us.
But he just wanted to know what we were doing.
Yeah.
He was like that even before we knew that he was a big movement man.
He was really a community person.
Yeah, he was.
Yeah.
Our little road was pretty close knit.
Mm-hmm.
Who was the one in the community that were involved in the movement?
What were they like?
They didn't take Mrs. Glover.
The one with Glover is the person who sticks out immediately.
She was a local teacher.
And she went to the meetings.
She made speeches.
And I told you, she was the one who stood in the little thing between the cops and us praying.
Her children, two of her children at least were involved in the movement, Faye and LaWita.
LaWita ended up going to the University of Illinois and becoming a lawyer in Chicago.
Faye became a teacher in Chicago.
This Glover was one of the outspoken women.
Mrs. Pearl Robinson was one of the active women.
I don't remember her making speeches.
Mrs. Virgil Robinson, again, was one of the active women.
Don't remember her speaking publicly anyplace.
So when you said they were active but they didn't speak publicly, what were some of the things that they would do?
Make sure people got to the polls to vote.
Make sure they tried to register to vote.
I think they took in civil rights workers.
A Claire, Claire, Claire, what's her name?
Lawson was Mrs. Pearl's daughter.
She was also one of the active women.
The Thomas says the owner of the sundry where everybody hung out in 64 had not been active before.
But the sundry was a place where people hung out.
There were people who were moved with people.
And I don't remember them ever being really active.
But they were okay with people using their hands.
In 64.
Not before 1964.
So some people are definitely responding to these outside people.
Is it because they're outside?
And they're white.
And I think people from a distance, we didn't really know them up close and personal.
And I think it was really something to see them walking in our neighborhood and talking to us and embracing us.
And people were sort of shocked by it.
I think so.
And did you become friends with any of the white volunteers?
Penny Patch?
Yeah, I remember Penny.
I wasn't really friends with her.
But Claire, O'Connor, from Minnesota.
We watched them.
Yeah, we watched them.
What are they going to do now?
Let's watch them.
Did you do gal with them or anything like that?
I was sort of off the table as far as my mom was concerned.
Because they were going to leave and you would be here.
And so I sort of worked with my friends.
When we did sit-in stuff, then we did it all together.
Did other people work with them?
Yeah.
I'm listening to some of them trying to keep you a little separate.
Trying to keep you safe.
Yeah, we had that trouble in the family before the 60s.
Yeah.
Like what kind of trouble?
Oh, it was serious trouble.
Gosh.
One of my uncles had been in town, not Batesville, Pope,
another little town, and he was jumped by a group of flight men
who went out with white men.
And that was not, you couldn't do that.
So they were going to teach the younger brother,
and I don't know which of the brothers they were after.
They were going to teach him a lesson.
But he was armed and dangerous.
So I don't know if more than one person was killed,
but I know one person was paralyzed.
One person was killed.
One of my uncles who had been in town,
one of my uncles who had been in World War II,
and my dad went to the aid of the younger brother.
And the one uncle took responsibility,
actually, it was just recently we found out that he didn't do it.
He left his car in town so they would think it was him,
took the weapon, and left over bullets, and got out of town.
And he was a grandmother and a younger cousin to the woods
and said, we'll kill her if you don't turn yourself in.
So he turned himself in, which was the plan in the first place.
And they brought him back to Batesville.
They first, you know, in Oxford, he was in Oxford for a while.
Brought him back to Batesville and tried him and found him guilty of murder
and electrocuted him, like in 1952.
I guess.
And then 11 months later, my dad died mysteriously.
The secret word in the family was, he was poisoned.
He died exactly 11 months later.
The family moved away to, after the trouble,
they sold the farm and moved to King's Court, Tennessee.
That's dad family?
Yeah.
Do you know how the family story, how they put it, is poison?
Yeah, they think.
There was a doctor who took care of the black families, Dr. Martin.
And he would make house calls.
He took care of everybody.
He would go to black gatherings.
And my dad was given medicine for blood pressure or something.
And that was, we think, what might have taken him out?
So were you aware of this at the time?
Oh no, I had no idea what death was.
I was aware that there was trouble, because I listened,
and Eve's dropped on adults all the time.
And when my dad died, my mom, my uncle told her,
not my, her brother, but her dad's brother came in to tell her he was gone.
He also came to tell her when Uncle Lionel was electrocuted.
And I heard it.
And so she called me in, because they were trying to figure out how to tell me.
And I thought, okay, so I already know, but I won't let them know I know.
And so I went inside and mother said, your dad's dead.
I said, okay, I guess I'll figure out how to cry at the funeral somehow.
It was like acting to me.
It was death that meant nothing to me.
It was just not real.
You know, you go and you do performance at the church.
And then you're going about your business.
So, not initially, I told you it was performance art.
When they brought the cat, I remember it very well.
And I don't know whether I was four or five years old.
They brought the casket into the church covered in the flag.
Yeah, he was in World War II.
He went overseas.
And my auntie started to cry.
And I had to nut her and say, it's not time yet.
We are doing performance here.
It's not time yet.
And then I watched my older cousin to see when I was supposed to start crying because I wasn't sure.
You know, and I would look back.
She was sitting on the front row and she was sitting in a row behind me.
And I'd look back.
And then when the preacher finished preaching and everybody finished singing and they opened the casket,
I looked back and she was squeezing her eyes together to make tears.
And I thought, oh, it's time.
And so I did my crying.
Yeah.
So because of that, you're extending family with more cautious around my folks?
No.
I don't think so.
They decided that that was why I was in the movement.
But they didn't say it to me directly.
I heard it.
Oh, you heard them talking about that.
Yeah.
And then when I went in to get my photo with the number,
there were a group of men sitting around in there and they said, girl, where's your daddy?
And they didn't know that they had found the wrong one.
And I said, I think you know better than I do.
Yeah.
But I didn't know they didn't know which of the Henderson guys was my dad.
And so I was talking about, oh, I know.
And I had gone up to see him when he was in jail there to take him ice cream.
And didn't understand why he didn't want me there.
He said to my sister, don't bring her back here.
And I thought, hi, I brought your ice cream.
And, hmm.
Why didn't you want to show them?
It was a gel.
He didn't want me associated or to be remembered that way.
And then I went move to California late 79.
And that was the one person who survived the younger uncle living in California.
He never came back to Mississippi.
And one of the reasons I wanted to go to California was to find out from him what actually happened that night.
Yeah.
When did he tell you?
He said, only I know.
And I will never tell.
And he cried.
And my auntie said to me, look after your uncle, he feels responsible for his brother's debts.
Okay.
So after he was gone, his wife told me that he had actually done the thing.
Why did they decide that the other brother would take responsibility?
I think that was the brother's decision.
And my uncle at the time was a teenager.
He was a young guy and somebody, and I don't know who yet.
I will find out.
Sent him away to the army.
That's how he got away.
Okay.
Somebody slipped him out of town.
Yeah.
But one of the family stories about my uncle is they gave him, he was a trustee in the gel.
And they gave him $500 to take to the bank just about the time the train was coming through.
And he took the money to the bank and went back to the jail.
So he actually could have escaped if he had wanted to.
He didn't want to.
I don't know what that was about.
And it's interesting because he has a son.
And we have never talked about it.
His son is maybe a year younger than I am.
And so you both lost your father?
Yeah.
And how do you sneak in the fact that your great-great-grandfather was the slave owner.
And he found it, he lived with his family, my folks, and found it a school for them.
In Penoly County until the 50s, there was a Henderson school.
Where all those little offspring went to school.
So was this the...
So he lived with his family, was this the fortress of the war?
He lived with the Black family?
Yes.
And he had...
And so then did he leave people land?
I think so.
I think the farm that they sold when they moved off to Tennessee was his land.
I need to do more research on it.
How can you say, yeah, did your family talk about that history at all?
No.
So you're on research on it?
Yeah.
Because I didn't know about him until one of my cousins, I'm trying to do the family tree
and talking about the Black people and the Native people.
And they said, what about Duncan?
I said, who?
Who is Duncan?
He's your great-great-grandfather.
How do you know that?
So I looked up the slave schedule and there he is, Duncan C. Henderson.
And he owned 13 people.
It's a dying...
There are no names, just ages.
And one of them, presumably, a great-great-grandfather?
Yes.
And it took some doing to find her name.
How did you find your name?
Yeah.
Not in the sense of anything, but one of my cousins who was doing a family tree,
I saw her online, so I sent her a note saying, are you my cousin that I met at my auntie's funeral?
And she said, yes, I'm the great-great-granddaughter of Classy, Idae Lena.
I said, that's my grandfather's name.
We found her name.
That's exciting.
It was.
It was very exciting.
I had to tell her that the next family reunion.
Have you looked at the land records going down?
No, I have not.
That might be interesting.
That's true.
You can look at the transfer.
My dad is a research looking at the transfer.
Yeah.
So you've started with your dad's grandfather?
That's grandfather.
I'll track it back or not, but that would be interesting.
I think so.
Yeah.
Did you participate in Freedom School in summer of 1964?
Did they have Freedom School?
I think they did, but I don't know that I participated.
I don't remember being in Freedom School classes.
I don't remember our Freedom Schools being as organized
as they were in other parts of the state.
No.
Mm-hmm.
I'm trying to look at my message.
So what did I do after all of that?
Yeah.
What did you do after all of that?
After the West Indies, I came back and Florence Tate again
was trying to keep me working and doing stuff
that I was supposed to do.
And of course, I would stray off.
I took a couple of classes at George Washington University
because I decided I wanted to be a doctor.
And I got myself a tutor for chemistry.
And that didn't last very long.
And then I quit another job.
I got another job at Children's Defense Fund of all places.
Yeah.
And I think I worked there half day as something.
I thought, no, this is not me.
What kind of work was it?
Secretarial, answering phones.
Then I worked for if goal for a minute.
They had an office in Washington.
Interreligious foundation for community organization.
They had a people who had been taking packages,
were taking care packages to Cuba.
Don't remember the order of that.
But Florence again called me up at some point and said,
why Dean, what are you doing?
Nothing.
Come to work with me tomorrow.
I said, okay.
And I went to work for the National Urban Coalition.
And the job there was to be a public relations writer.
And I thought, okay, go and interview so and so, okay.
And they had a little magazine that I helped with.
And then I read in the Washington Afro
that Columbia University had a program for minority journalists.
And I applied and got accepted.
So I went off to New York in 1974 to the Michele Clark Fellowship Program at Columbia.
And became a reporter.
It was funny because I was too shy.
And I know you can't see that now.
I can't see that in the child.
You're talking about like acting up.
It was a sneaky shy.
I walked around with some woman running for governor of New York
and didn't ask her a single question.
Walked around with her for hours.
Yeah.
And they were like, what are we going to do with her?
She's not, you know, where were you working?
I didn't have a job yet.
I was at Columbia and we were putting out a little weekly paper called Deadline.
And so they sent for Earl Caldwell,
the guy that met on the poor people's campaign.
So you better come over here.
Rodin is not participating.
I was kind of participating, but not really.
And Earl had me calling people on the phone, taking notes.
And then he would put the note, I would have to call him back if I didn't write down everything he thought I should write.
And it was like, okay, drive me crazy.
And then I was assigned to go to the prison
and to interview a man who had been imprisoned in North Carolina.
I think he was sentenced to life or something.
And they let the prisoners out to fight a fire.
And he hit the tracks.
Ran away.
Yeah, he ran away.
Went to New York, was in a car accident.
That's how they got him again.
And I went to interview him and wrote a story about his life.
It was interesting to me.
And he was like, you know, I'm just like a club, you know.
I'm just like, I'm just like, you know, I'm just like, you know, I'm just like, you know, I'm just like, you know, I'm just like a club, you know.
And then I, that was the one story I really liked.
Then I went to the Newport Jazz Festival.
And went to talk to one of the old musicians because I knew nothing about it.
And he told me about the various people.
And I wrote about Cafe Society.
And then I went off to my first newspaper job at the end of the summer in Mount Vernon, New York, working for the Daily Argus.
Yeah.
And I was a little scared.
The first story was of a kid who had, the elevator was broken.
And she stuck her head through the glass to see what it was and was decapitated.
Yeah, that was my first story.
Oh, wow.
First story was front page, huh?
Yeah.
And I did the newspaper stuff for 28 years.
So I guess you found what you liked?
I loved it.
What can I tell you?
That's great.
How do you think your involvement in the movement, shape the person you did it?
I think it was the movement and the family.
Because my family was pretty strong.
Uh-huh.
My grandmother teaching in her little school.
My grandfather, we never mentioned him too much.
But I hung out with him.
He was the person who people came to see when they were ill and didn't go to the normal doctor.
He made medicine.
And a farmer.
He was a farmer and he made medicine.
Uh-huh.
He wanted me to be a lawyer.
And at some point I said I was going to do that.
But I didn't.
I didn't really want to do that.
You know?
Yeah.
I wish I had learned more about herbs from him.
Uh-huh.
I didn't.
So now I study on my own.
The movement.
I'm still in touch with some of the people like Charlie and Frank.
I don't see him every day.
And that often.
But I have to check in on him every now and then.
Gene Wheeler Smith is young.
He's in my neighborhood.
So occasionally we will connect again.
Yeah, the movement is us.
And it is a part of my life still.
What do you think it's important for people to know about the movement?
That at a time when it was really dangerous in the United States that young people stood
up to power in this country.
And like they are doing now pretty much.
And that you can do it.
And yes, you lose a few on the way.
But you can't let it stop you.
Yeah.
Can you think of other things that I haven't asked you about?
No.
What didn't you ask me about?
Spiritual stuff.
And how I left church as soon as I turned.
18.
Yes, I did.
I didn't play the piano anymore.
I have a piano now.
But I stopped playing at church.
I stopped going to church.
And I think one of my favorite things was I come not to bring peace but a sword.
It's time for us to fight.
You know?
That was before I went to prison.
State prison, Mississippi, parchment, overnight.
We were awful.
In Rosedale, the churches were afraid to open their doors for movement meetings.
So we decided we were going to meet on the steps of the church.
And we had a little rally on the steps of the church.
And I don't remember what the issue was at the time.
But when people left, as we were leaving, most people had gone already.
Maybe 10 or 11 of us were left behind talking about what our next move should be
and how we can get the churches to open their doors.
These people jumped out of the bushes with their high-powered rifles.
And marched us off to jail, which was right there, a block away, a half block.
Processed us because they wanted to know who was in their town.
And then after they got all our names and addresses and all of that,
they took us off to parchment.
Parchment, prison.
That scared me.
But we couldn't let scared show.
And I remember they took the men off the bus.
I don't remember how many men were on there.
And left just the women.
And we got our courage up by cursing.
You touched them?
Oh, yeah.
And then they brought in a trustee woman.
We had to strip.
They stripped, searched us, and gave us only back our top clothes.
And put us in cells for women to a cell with two still bunk beds still.
And I don't know.
Maybe we were there for two or three hours before they came around with the big jar of stuff for us to drink.
I don't know what it was.
But immediately after you drank it, you have to use the toilet.
There's one toilet for four women.
It was ridiculous.
After that, maybe an hour or so later, they put us back on the bus
and took us back to Bolivar County to Cleveland, not Rosedale.
And then from Cleveland, we went back to Rosedale.
And then I think the Delta Ministry had bailed us out or something.
And I ran across the road to the house where I was staying.
But sick.
They gave us something to drink.
I wish I knew what.
Did you do that with everybody?
Yeah.
Well, I don't, I mean, all of the people who were arrested in that group, yes.
Martin Thomas, who had been one of the white guys from Boston, didn't get out immediately.
He was in Cleveland.
And they beat him fiercely.
The other prisoners.
He came out looking really, really bad.
I mean, even his ears were bashed.
And I think his dad sent for him after that and he had to go home.
Did that intimidation all that experience that it's what you know?
No.
I decided I wouldn't go back to jail.
And I said, you shouldn't tell this, but I had put a little pistol in my purse.
Although I couldn't shoot it.
Didn't know how to shoot it.
But you're still packing.
I was packing here.
Yeah.
No.
And if I had, I probably would have thrown it at somebody.
For him, that's all.
That's right.
But you better be off carrying this off.
That's true.
Other other thing?
No, I can't think of anything.
I used to give my little sister, my younger sister is 12 years younger than I am.
And I was sneak little buttons onto her clothes.
I said, put this on when we get to town.
Did your sister be a walking billboard?
Yeah.
Did she put she in?
She was too young to know.
She was too young to know anything.
If I was 16, she was four.
Had no clue.
Freedom now.
That's right.
I didn't have a little hand stuck up.
We started doing that.
What about the marriage march?
I didn't do a lot on the marriage march.
I did go.
Oh, that's a terrible story.
A doctor came from Detroit to help out the marches.
And he kept talking about the poor downed rotten people of Mississippi.
I went to the marches, but I had to go home first to see my mother.
Because the marches were nearby.
And he was saying that poor downed rotten new grows.
And people burned rags at home to keep the mosquitoes away.
We were driving down one of the little streets in baseball, and I would stop the car.
And I went and jumped up and down on somebody's burning a rag.
Molotov cocktail.
I said what that poor man.
Yes.
And then we dropped him off at the marches.
They were in, I don't know where they were.
Pope was someplace.
And noticed that somebody was following us.
So I stopped at my sister's restaurant.
A little sister said somebody's following us.
She gave me a 38 and put some bullets in it.
I said, right, facing the back window of the car.
They get too close to the car, shoot out the back window.
We can replace that.
I said okay.
And I put the gun in my purse and we went back to Jackson.
Nothing happened.
I guess they figured as much because the car stopped following us.
Were you in Greenwood when Stokely Carmichael made you?
Yes, I was actually.
Yes, I was there.
But I had just gone up for the day.
I didn't march.
We went up.
I told you I was sick of the marches.
And I heard the speech.
I heard Rick's first.
And I had been at the SNCC meeting when Stokely Carmichael was elected.
You know?
In Nashville?
You there, you.
Uh-huh.
And I didn't think a lot of it at the time.
I didn't know why it became such a big deal later.
Then I understood it a little later on.
It took me a minute.
But we left the march.
I left with Frank and Jean again and we went into Greenville for something.
And then we came back to Jackson.
And I went to the rally in Jackson.
What did you think when Stokely Carmichael made his speech at the time?
What did you think about the idea of black power?
I thought it was necessary.
I didn't think that was so far fetched.
You know?
That was how we started.
I think it, what we didn't call it, black power.
But that black people needed to mobilize and do things for themselves.
So I thought that was right on the money.
I was surprised that it turned off so many people.
You know?
What do you mean?
Mm-hmm.
Um, by then the Deacons for Defense and Justice had unveiled themselves.
And I think on that Meredith March.
I don't know if anybody is going to be mad at me.
I don't care.
People were walking around armed.
Uh-huh.
Making sure that everything was okay.
Not flunting weapons but being armed anyway.
Mm-hmm.
Did that make you feel safer?
I didn't feel unsafe.
I guess I'm just, you know, I didn't feel unsafe.
Yeah.
Can you explain to me?
No.
I went, while I was in school, Ben.
The one who wanted me to act more like a girl, uh, was killed.
And I saw that on TV.
And kind of lost it briefly.
Um, somebody sent me a ticket to come home and I went down for the funeral.
And thought, what a waste.
You know, how did that happen?
And then I went back to college.
Who didn't get in touch with this family or anything.
And how was he killed?
The police officers saw him.
He had gone to a restaurant to get a sandwich for his wife or something.
And they recognized him from the old days and killed him.
That was what we were told.
Yeah.
There was a demonstration over in Jackson State, right?
The police were going to campus.
Mm-hmm.
And Ben wasn't on campus.
He wasn't a college student.
He had been married probably less than a year.
I think he was staying with his mom and trying to get a job
of working some non-movement job.
Yeah, that was kind of a...
He's been lost.
Yeah, I mean, I just emotionally.
I don't know how.
How can you do that?
I'm trying to get a job on the plantations,
trying to organize farm workers and nothing happens.
You know?
We knew how to run.
If you don't know somebody who's saving it,
you don't know how to run.
You know?
He didn't have a chance.
Yeah.
Yeah, and final thoughts?
No.
Except it's kind of scary now.
And we had better figure out how to mobilize ourselves again.
What do you think of the current work?
Actually, and this is terrible,
but I try not to pay attention.
I try not to pay attention.
It's too painful.
Like, why are we going through this again?
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
At home, and I'm hopefully we'll go later this month
to see my family.
One of my nephews is a deputy sheriff in Batesville.
And I thought, oh my goodness.
Okay.
But he also is a preacher.
So do you feel like you had something to do
with the impossible for him to be a deputy?
Probably.
And one of the things I used to do,
and he talked to me about it,
as I used to take books home for them,
my nieces and nephews.
That's what they got for Christmas.
And that was their Christmas present.
You got to know where you came from.
And he said he would try so hard to read those books.
Yeah.
Would you have any advice for the young people
who are living in today's movement?
I wish I did.
I do not.
Because I don't know.
It's so weird now.
You know, if you listen to Mr. Trump,
and all of the stuff that comes out of his mouth
is, oh, what if you come to Trump?
What is this?
And it's scary to me.
Because at least then we had a close knit community.
Now we're scattered.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
So how do you...
I guess you cannot do it across racial lines.
You have to be with people who like-minded people.
Mm-hmm.
I hope I didn't talk to you at Europe.
And if you come up with questions later,
you can always call me.
I will.
Okay.
This has been a presentation of the Library of Congress
and the Smithsonian National Museum
of African American History and Culture.